j'empêcherai quiconque de s'échapper de
la boucle croyez moi
j'ai réuni les plus grands chasseurs à
travers toutes les réalités
à commencer par le meilleur convaincre
mandeau m'a coûté un tas de crédit mais
telle est la voie
le plan semer le chaos et je compte bien
sur eux pour y arriver
menace le plus fort de tous les
gladiateurs personne ne l'a jamais
vaincu
car comme une crêpe prête à mettre la
main à la pâte et mahler elle s'est
juste une guerrière barbares met à mort
en explorant lille ils auront des
comptes à régler et des contrats remplir
le temps qu'on se prépare pour la
prochaine phase et tout ça n'est que le
début
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous attendez rejoignez la
chasse
ils l'ont fait qu on est en vie oui mais
le poids 0 et exposez vous devez y
entrer moi qui espérais ne plus voir
d'image de moi l'intérieur de la boucle
bien compris madame je me mets et
surtout d'attirer pas l'attention 17
donc je dois stabiliser le zéro et
refermez le pont sans que personne ne
s'en échappe
facile ok repérer les meilleurs
chasseurs dans chaque réalité
si ces intérêts à fonctionner
[Musique]